Carter page according to the Washington
Post the FBI obtained a secret court
order in the FISA Court to monitor the
communications of Carter page who was an
adviser to Donald Trump now he has not
been charged with anything Pat it's not
that there's no indication of whether or
not he will be charged with anything but
this is a very consistent theme that
we're seeing with the Trump
administration and has in the Trump
campaign more specifically of
relationships with Russians
relationships and communications with
that borderline enough for monitoring to
take place underneath the FISA warrant
and Carter page is certainly at the
forefront when it comes to this Russia
investigation because before he joined
the Trump campaign Carter page was a
nobody he were more an investment bank
but he also had deep ties to Russia he
always excuses the actions of Vladimir
Putin and apologizes for what we do here
in the United States he's lived in
Russia for three years and he's willing
to testify two panels in the house and
senate so i'd like to see that yeah i
think it would be a a good move for him
to do that particularly because he's not
really good when it comes to testimony
he's not really good even when it comes
to giving interviews for the media it's
quite hilarious I don't know if you have
that cliff let's see how he does but I'm
just asking you straight up like just
for a straight answer you're saying I
can't confirm her to not USA TODAY's
reported it you told one reporter I had
no meetings with the Russians and now
you're telling me I had no means of the
Russians about the things they were
talking about I'm just trying to get a
straight answer like did you meet Sergei
kiss lock in Cleveland did you talk to
him I'm not going to deny that I talked
with them although I don't with it I
will say that I never met him anywhere
outside of Cleveland let's just say that
not the only time if you met him was in
Cleveland I what that I may have met him
possibly what it might have been in
cleve oh wow okay I'm sorry I'm you see
my face I'm like wow so um yeah I would
love for him to testify before congress
because clearly clearly he doesn't do a
good job but one point that i do have to
add to this pad is that the presence of
a FISA warrant while it does for the
narrative of what happened in the
campaign with Russia is relatively easy
to get a war
and I think there's ninety-five percent
approval of these warrants so it doesn't
mean that he did anything wrong but
Carter page himself makes himself look
like he's done something wrong right but
the FBI would need probable cause to
request that yeah well I mean there's a
lot of debate on the probable cause
portion of obtaining pfizer warning a
warrant but I will say this again Carter
page whether or not a FISA warrant ever
existed Carter page looks guilty as hell
today's episode of the david pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
I glasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five day home try-on from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription into I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like an an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
three hundred dollars for prescription
glasses with Warby Parker they start at
just 95 bucks mine cost that including
lenses and for every pair sold they give
a pair to someone in need so to try the
five pairs and support the david pakman
show go to Warby Parker trial com /t DPS